- So you just turned 50
and you had a surprise
birthday party right?
- Ah yes.
- [Kelly] How did it go?
- It was a surprise
my sons took me out
which I was hoping I wouldn't
have to pick up the bill.
(Ms. Pat and Kelly laugh)
- But you did?
- But it worked out really well
but I learned something since I'm 50.
- Okay.
- [Ms. Pat] So I wish people would realize
that I'm a plus size woman.
When I park I need a sign to say I'm fat
and it.
(Kelly laughs)
And they park too close to my door.
- [Kelly] Oh so you can't get in your car?
- [Ms. Pat] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Ms. Pat] So the one
last week I had to go
and I had on these little
liquid pants like young girls.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so I couldn't get in my car
I had to take 'em off.
(crowd laughs)
- Wait what?
- [Ms. Pat] Cause I couldn't
spread my legs that wide
to get over the console.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh you came through the passenger.
- Yes.
But I'm out there with
not matching underwear
and I'm driving and I'm like oh Lord.
If the police pulled me over
then he gonna think I'm
naked from the front.
(Ms. Pat laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- And I'm driving down 40 miles going home
and I'm just sticking to the seat
and I'm.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I'm sweating and
I'm calling my husband
and I'm in my underwear.
He was like 'why?'
And I was like it's a long story.
And I was like I'm just
gonna put a sign on my car,
I'm fat,
be courteous and give me
room to get in my car.
- Be courteous,
not fat,
just thicker.
That's all.
But wait Ice Cube sent
you a birthday message.
- Oh my God.
So girl if I had on a spank that day
I would've died.
- Wait,
so wait,
I wanna see this.
I wanna show everyone real quick,
wait let's see,
let's see.
- Happy birthday Ms.Pat
from your homie Ice Cube.
Keep doing what you're doing.
I see you out there girl.
Aye aye aye.
(Kelly laughs)
- That is so cool.
He's so nice.
I met him once.
He was so nice.
- I've never met him
but I've always dreamed
of working with Ice Cube.
Two people I wanted meet
Whitney Houston and Ice Cube
and Whitney checked out too soon.
- Okay I was like,
that's,
that's gonna be tough.
- It's gonna be tough unless
I meet the hologram but.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm like I forget this is daytime TV.
Catch up y'all catch up.
- Catch up catch up.
- So I always wanted to
work and meet Ice Cube.
And I worked for V103 in Atlanta, Georgia
with The Big Tigger Morning Show
and they know how much I love Ice Cube.
He called in and I,
my wigs fell off that morning.
(Kelly laughs)
So my husband called in
right after Ice Cube.
And I was like who is this?
Do I know you?
- Who this?
Wrong number.
- Well I was like baby,
Ice Cube just called me.
Can you call me back tomorrow?
(Kelly laughs)
- So wait,
I wanna,
you're so funny and I wanna talk
about your new special.
So your special on Netflix
it's called "Y'all Wanna
Hear Something Crazy"
which I love the title of that.
So Wanda Sykes,
I heard she produced it right?
- Wanda Sykes produced it.
- I love females promoting females.
- Yeah.
- This is awesome.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- When I got the deal from Netflix
I immediately said I want
Wanda Sykes to produce it.
- Yeah.
- And then after Wanda Sykes
we brought on Robert Townsend.
And they was like
'Oh we don't know if Robert
Townsend will do it.'
I'm like Robert Townsend.
Oh look at it.
I was like he's gonna do it.
I'm gonna pray.
And we worked out some things
and Robert Townsend did it
but I gotta tell you.
- Yeah.
- When you ask Robert
Townsend to do your special
you'd better be serious about comedy.
'Cause he made me practice
for four hours a week,
four hours for one day.
And I had to send him all
of my recordings on zoom
which I thought it was the craziest thing
I ever had ever done.
- Is it 'cause he wanted to know
how to capture like the joke
and like and make sure.
- He wanted to make sure
you was delivering it right.
He wanted make sure
there was no fat on it.
He was cutting stuff.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- He was helping me
put stuff together.
And I was like this is stupid.
That's what I said.
- Yeah.
- I dreaded it every Wednesday.
I was like oh I gotta go
talk to Robert Townsend.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- But when it came out
I was like oh my God
I'm so glad I listened to him.
- Oh that's so awesome
that's a good experience.
(crowd claps)
- Thank you Robert.
Thank you.
- Yeah.
Well we need a break.
Ms. Pat special
Y'all Wanna Hear Something Crazy"
is streaming right now on Netflix
and make sure to watch the Ms. Pat Show
on BET and BET plus.